GOOD MORNING COLLEAGUES --
RULES COMMITTEE OF THE
SEPTEMBER FIFTH IS HEREBY CALLED
ORDER PLEASE ADVISE AN AUDIO
RECORDING OF TODAY'S FOR SHE
IS BEING MADE AS ALSO BEING
TELEVISED -- MANAGE SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL COOLEY
CUNNINGHAM CARILLO FLORA GRAYSON
KAMLAGER-DOVE MAIENSCHEIN
MATHIS QUIRK SILVA HEAR
FROM US RIVAS WICKS
WE HAVE A QUORUM AND WE HAVE A
CONSENT AGENDA MOST OF THE
SENATE JENNIFER SURE OF COURSE
SO SECONDED BY THIS COMMON
ADULT DOES HAVE TO PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL COOLEY HI COOLEY AYE
CUNNINGHAM CARILLO FLORA FOR I
GRAYSON REASON I KAMLAGER-DOVE
I'VE KAMLAGER-DOVE AYE
MAIENSCHEIN AYE MAIENSCHEIN
AYE MATHIS MEMBERS I'D BURKE
CELLPHONE FIRST OF ALL I RAMOS
SCI FI NUMBERS I RIVAS WICKS
QUESTION OF THAT MOTIONS PASSED
I DO WANT TO SAY THIS IS OUR
LAST REGULAR SCHEDULE RULES
COMMITTEE MEETING OF THE YEAR
WE MAY YET FIND OCCASION TO COME
TOGETHER AS NEEDED ON THE
CALL THE CHAIRMAN I THANK YOU
ALL FOR YOUR SERVICE AND --
WISH YOU GREAT FOR TO THE PERSON
PRESS THE NEXT HANDFUL DAIS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I DO IS JUST